oh yeah so this trailer happened at
comic-con I want to talk about it
because it was probably my favorite
trailer I saw comic-con yes this is the
trailer for Wonder Woman when I first
saw it that first shot I was like holy
crap it's the Little Mermaid I don't
know what you want to do with that
information that's just that was my
go-to thought I was like it's the beach
scene in Little Mermaid but Diana sees
Chris Pine Steve Trevor and she's like
you're a man I've never seen a man so
I'm gonna pal around with you during
this war why not and you do see more
humor in this that's something that the
Wonder Woman trailer and the Justice
League trailer buzz showed us that
they're incorporating more humor into
their universe which is a good thing I
mean I don't require humor for
everything in every moment but people
human beings just throw out humor it's
just what we do sometimes like the
perfect response to Wonder Woman be like
I don't have a father I was brought to
life by Zeus is crisp lines reaction
regions land there's like well that's
neat I mean what do you say to that you
know this woman's probably crazy this
case though it just happens to be true I
was most impressed with the action in
this trailer it just showed Wonder Woman
is business she is business taking care
of that business it was great and the
second time I was watching this trailer
I was like wait a minute Batman versus
Superman that's right when he was
opening the files you know that really
convenient file pack about everybody and
Bruce Wayne was watching one room he's
looking through Wonder Woman's file it
shows her next to Chris Pine and I
believe it's 1918 World War one style so
that you see the DC Cinematic Universe
starting to build when she has that
shield man and the bullets are just
hitting that shield and she's just
blocking I mean I just love that it
almost looks like the action sequences
in this movie with her shield and her
you know super-strength could be like
the action sequences from Captain
America the First Avenger only just
don't montage through it show it let's
be honest if they just don't montage
through the action scenes we're looking
at some good stuff air the line I liked
was when that one lady was like hi I'm
his secretary she's like what's a
secretary and she's like I do what he
wants and I do what he tells me she's
like oh well where we come from that's
called slavery I won't lie I read a lot
a lot of the new 52 run and Brian
Azzarello slender woman was awesome I
stopped reading Wonder Woman after Brian
Azzarello left but from what he did in
that arc is a complete story it's
fantastic you should read
it shows that she just is a badass and
she takes on the gods looks like she's
not going to take on a lot of gods
there's a war going on so maybe she does
take on Ares at some point God of War
during a war it only makes sense but I
think the characters of Wonder Woman and
Steve Trevor are gonna be great together
I think Chris Pine is gonna bring a lot
to the movie and putting Wonder Woman in
a war just I think she's just gonna win
the war that's the end of the war
happens because Wonder Woman wins the
war nothing but aces for this trailer
humor action awesome but I want to know
what you think about it so the Wonder
Woman Comic Con trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more